on China's East Coast the economies of
prosperous cities like Shanghai and
Guangzhou have been growing for decades
but in China's Far West there's a boom
in construction of what journalists
former inmates and the United States
government call concentration camps a
vast and growing network of what the
Chinese government refers to as
vocational training centers are believed
to hold between 1 and 3 million people
perhaps as much as a quarter of the
Muslim population of Xinjiang province
outside the camps shinjang is described
by its Weger residence as a police state
where the Chinese government subjects
the population to round-the-clock
surveillance many traditional practices
have been outlawed intended to impose
Chinese cultural unity on a
multicultural region shinjang a region
the size of Alaska is home to 23 million
people 45% of whom are we curse a people
who identify closely with the culture of
Central Asia the remainder are mostly
Han Chinese the majority ethnic group of
mainland China at first the Chinese
government denied the existence of the
camps the allegation that millions of
weaker people were imprisoned in the
re-education Center is completely not
true confronted with overwhelming
evidence from satellite photography
witness testimonies and internal
Communist Party documents the Chinese
government has been forced to
acknowledge their existence the Chinese
government has a set type of vocational
education and training centers these
programs are preventive counterterrorism
measures Beijing now says the camps are
necessary to counter Islamic terrorism
and to quell a violent separatist
movement such as we go riots back in
2009 that left 200 mostly Han Chinese
dead
and a terror attack by the East
Turkestan Islamic movement in the heart
of Tiananmen Square that killed five
people party officials describe the
training centers as paths out of poverty
designed to teach basic skills like
sewing and reading the wiggers are
Canaries in a coal mine
and this is a life-and-death situation
for the weavers the wiggers are facing
an existential threat Nuri Turkel is an
attorney and an activist I was born in
the education camp at the height of the
Cultural Revolution and oddly enough the
history is repeating itself an American
of Weger heritage i sat down with Turkel
to discuss what he considers the
greatest humanitarian crisis in the
world today
you have described the situation in
western China is the largest internment
of an ethnic minority in history since
World War two right what is going on
there and how do we know about what's
going on there so back in 2016
China's government identified this
Chinese version of ahead of Heitmann
by the name Cheng Cheng hua who was
ruling Tibet until late 2016 so they
brought him into power in the wiggler's
homeland and provide him all the tools
and power and the resources that could
provide a final solution to the Weger
problem so with that he initiated
through his local legislation
legislative body to formulate what's
known as the the extrema fication
measure that sanction some of the most
acceptable behaviors in the society such
as growing beard adherent to Islamic
diet that's illegal did that become
illegal interfering your children's love
affairs with none weaker individuals so
this paved the way for the construction
of concentration camps so this this
individual by the name change an NGO has
quoted an AFP that these camps need to
be constructed to teach liked school
managed like prison and protect like a
military with the purposes of breaking
wheelers lineage origin and roots so the
Xi Jinping government have been waging
this modern-day cultural genocide in an
ethnic specific concentration camps in
the last two three years according to
Pentagon and the State Department
anywhere between two to three million
Weaver's and other Turkic people have
been locked up in these camps for many
of these prisoners who are intern there
there's no trial for them is that
correct this is a no right zone as
perfectly described by the UN no nothing
no access to lawyers no access to courts
most of these people have been taken to
the camps for several things one passed
the rioting
past teaching pass expression of
political views or social views or
travel history philanthropic work
philanthropist work and the the thongs
that they performed on the stage maybe
inadvertently promoting ethnic pride
family connection with overseas or
foreign-based wiggers such as myself so
those are the things can make you a
target how do they come up with the list
of people should go to the jail
artificial intelligence and the
authorities subjected wiggers to
mandatory biometric collection DNA
sampling that helped the Chinese
government to build large database
artificial intelligence database I want
to get into some of that because that's
a really fascinating 21st century
technology or just a survey on very
large population but I first want to
just clarify with you some of the more
credible but shocking allegations about
what goes on in these camps yeah for
example torture yes
the there Weaver's and other Turkic
Muslims being detained go through both
psychological and physical torture at
least one of those survivors managed to
come to the United States have described
some of the typical psychological and
physical tortures poor hygiene no
dietary arrangement even people and
sleeping in a crowded prison cell and in
in turn and also the most disturbing way
of torturing these weekers most enough
some of the most jarring aspect of these
prison camps one is to force renounce
and denouncing the ethnic and religious
background so you have to denounce your
religion calling it evil and replacing
all the love and affection to God with
Xi Jinping and Xi Jinping thoughts
and also survivors these female
survivors one based in Turkey one based
in the United States who testified
before the US Congress told us that the
wiggle woman have been given some sort
of mysterious pills they forced us to
take unknown pills and drink some kind
of white liquid the pill caused us to
lose consciousness and reduced our
cognition level the white liquid caused
loss of menstruation in some woman and
extreme bleeding in others and even
death I also experienced torture in a
Tiger chair the second time I was
detained I was taken to a special room
in the place in a high chair bands held
my arms and the legs in place and
tighten it when they pressed a button
the gods put a helmet on my shaved head
each time I was electrocuted my whole
body would shake violently and I could
feel the pain in my veins I thought I
would rather die than go through this
torture I begged them to kill me
satellite imageries only shows the
facilities but we do not know what
actually happens inside the camps other
than the experience being described by
some of the survivors or the victims of
the detainees been taken to the camp
though shockingly available regarding
those satellite imagery is there have
been what appears to be large
crematorium built around them is that
something you're aware of we know that
or is it just an you know when when the
terminology comes up the concentration
camp for example people reasonably ask
well it's not really concentration camps
yet in the sense that the Nazi Germany
set up because there's no gas chambers
we don't know we don't know really what
is happening and how it's happening
inside the camp's it's the same thing
the world did not know what really
happened in Auschwitz and Dachau
until after the World War two until six
million Jews lost their lives so it's
hard to know what is really happening
so it would be useful for some
journalists or governments it or
international body to go actually see
these crematoria why would they build
cro materia and why would they post job
advertisement if it's not expended if
it's not a a large facilities all around
this modern-day concentration camps that
have been identified by through
technology and in another question
legitimate question you take in people
in such a large number and more than ten
percent the weekly population have been
gone into the camps what on earth that
we don't see anyone leaving why do we
always hear somebody leaving as a dead
person what happened to the rest of the
population
so Radio Free Asia reported this pre
materia construction that disturbed many
of us that shows that there is some
active the it shows that something
unthinkable is taking place recently
you British TV station ITV broadcast an
interview and in it in that interview a
Chinese security official who agreed to
speak said that we locked up people
under the false premises that they will
need to be educated
and also because of the people gone
insane
we need mental hospital to keep them
otherwise they will be causing a lot of
criminal activities or committing
criminal activities in the society
originally China just simply denied the
presence of these camps right so so so
do we have to really wait until some
bodily damage actually seen to act or
are we gonna act based on what do we
already know based on what happened to
people in the history when they were
locked up in such large numbers based on
their ethnicity and religion so the old
indicators and trajectory shows a
disturbing image you know this is why
we've been telling the world telling
various audience that the wiggers are
Canaries in coal mine and this is a
life-and-death situation for the weavers
the wiggers are facing an existential
threat and and no world leader either in
office or outside the government no
former or current heads of state have
taken up the cause yet which is very
disturbing
China has of course their own point of
view on all this they see the wiegert's
as an existential threat to the Chinese
state right that's why that justifies
their harsh crackdown from their point
of view they claim there is a
secessionist movement they claim there
is a jihadi terrorist movement to what
extent does that exist in western China
any type of violent incidents that has
been cited in the newspapers and even in
the Chinese publication predates 2015
and the concentration camps start being
built in late 2016
mm-hmm so why would you do something
that has already been under control if
somebody commits acts of terrorism in a
reasonable societies in the reasonable
countries you would have at Lee
someone if not a investigative
journalist a lawyer would have access to
get to the bottom of what really
happened if this is about terrorism let
me highlight this the Secretary of State
for the United States would not come up
and say as he did about ten days ago
the way that the Chinese government's a
treatment of the wiggers is a stain on
the century to be fair though there is a
secessionist movement in among leaders
is there not the weavers have had two
independent republics in the modern
history the first one is in 1933 the
second one is in 1944 both of them named
East Turkestan Republic that the name is
Turkestan is related to that modern
Weger political history so the second
one was established with the help of the
Soviets and also destroyed with the help
of the Soviets five years later because
of that glorious history that the
wiggers always nostalgic about the
wiggers desire for independence homeland
has never disappeared even after the
brutal occupation of the mouse communist
China in 1949 with the help of Stalin
but as far as the movement is concerned
because of the ongoing daylight killing
of the wiggers aspiration and body and
soul and dignity more Weaver's are
inclined to go for a separate
independent and we would state these
days which is we should be respected
because the many what legitimate dissent
but China find this is very useful
excuse because when you lobby advocate
Weger rights around the world any
country has a diplomatic relationship
with China cannot publicly support any
separatist or secessionist movement so
the Chinese use this as a tool to
silence some governments claiming that
there is a organized separatist movement
the distinct the desire ultimate desired
the weaker people's desire versus what
actually happening have to be
distinguished so if this has been going
on for a long long time why has it
gotten so much worse in the last 10
years if you look through the Chinese
history us against them mentality have
been very evident as it has shown in the
way that they treated the Tibetan people
and in the way that they have treated
non-han chinese individuals or subjects
throughout history and also to the
Chinese government's mindset as they
become bigger and more powerful they
need to also promote this oneness to
others like the wiggers and Tibetans so
you either become one of them who all
will take you out the only one logical
reasonable explanation is racism the
Chinese people have not realized
including those in power that their
language their way of life their culture
even religion is not are not something
universal as such the others should not
be forced to accept it because in the
minds of the Chinese officials
if the wiggers are not transformed by
force as the Chinese ambassador in
Washington shamelessly stated in the
Western media that the wiggers must be
converted into normal human beings
eventually they become a political
threat so the diversity that the people
in liberal societies cherish admire
appreciate had become something kept the
Chinese officials awake at night talk to
me a little bit about the Trump
administration response to this how has
it been in your opinion the United
States government deserves a lot of
credit particularly members of Congress
vice president Mike Pence Secretary of
State Pompeyo and Sam Brownback who's
leading the effort and religious freedom
there's are a lot of credit but had they
done enough
no the response have been quite strong
in individual level in the Congress and
in administration but it has not been
collective to rectify at least going
after some of the human rights abusers
who should be sanctioned under the
global Magnitsky Act which is very
powerful tool that the United States
government along with several other
Western democracies have for singling
out individuals in the Chinese
government for sanctions
yes but the Treasury Department
Secretary maneechan
has not been fully onboard on this
effort I still can't help but note the
irony though that an administration that
called for the total shutdown of Muslims
entering the United States to quote them
and curtailing refugees into the United
States is now probably doing more about
the Uighur situation at least vocally
compared to almost any Muslim nation on
earth it makes sense to me because this
is not about the Wiggles anymore the the
Chinese way of treating the wiggers I
think woke up policy experts and
government officials or people with
influence because this is going to
become a part of problem worldwide we
already seen according to the New York
Times and more than a dozen countries
adopting Chinese Way of surveilling
their own population
and even countries like New Zealand
looking into the way that the Chinese
police conducted itself and we've seen
what's happening Hong Kong the Hong Kong
police actually gets help from chin John
police yeah and also we've seen
countries like Venezuela already adopted
Chinese way of issuing identification
card to even monitor who's Warren who
whatnot and we're also seeing some
Western countries Poland Hungary Greece
looking to Chinese way of building state
security apparatus I guess I'm just most
surprised by the Muslim countries
reaction rate the Prime Minister of
Pakistan claimed not to have heard of
the Weger crisis at all Saudi Arabia we
mentioned earlier
has praised China for their treatment of
the weavers and Egypt has actually
deported weekers back to China why is
this happening from countries that
should have real sympathy with the
weaker population there are a few
reasons one these societies are not a
free societies like ours and here or the
Western Europe the people don't have a
voice and then to most of these Muslim
countries have been criticized for their
own human rights records and they don't
get criticism from China so you scratch
my back and I scratch yours type of
mentality so as long as the Chinese
don't interfere quote-unquote in
domestic affairs of these Muslim
countries they also make a pledge not to
interfere with the Chinese at the end of
the day these are authoritarian
countries that are bound more by their
belief in governance and they are by
their ethnicity or religion right and
then the third there are their silence
have been by out by Chinese money and
finally there's an anti West sentiment
in some Muslim societies that have been
utilized effectively by the Chinese so
they convince those Muslim leaders look
they are not against the the China is
not against Muslims we against against
the Western government orchestrated
so-called human rights concerns so I
want to just talk briefly about the
types of surveillance that goes on by
the Chinese government against the
weaker population the surveillance is
very high-tech right and it enlists a
lot of large corporations and they
require for example installing spyware
on people's cell phones is it what else
do they do they have this mobile police
station established or set up on the
streets every hundred yards that you go
you will be stopped or seen a mobile
police station they call it convenient
police station they are allowed to check
your mobile phone if you don't have this
compulsory spyware they install before
they force you to install
check if there's any content that are
banned in China such as Crescent star or
certain sky-blue color because it's the
color of the Weaver flag verses from the
Quran or images of someone some
individuals that the China's government
does not like I've heard even not having
a phone makes you suspicious yes and
also a based on Human Rights Watch
report published recently charging your
phone too many times can be reason
what's wrong with that because that
means that you are using it too much
surfing the internet communicating your
electric bill
Human Rights Watch even stated that
leaving the back door of your house
which is you know these kind of things
are perfectly legal but the Chinese made
it illegal for their own purposes and
also the other thing that they do they
are sending the Chinese cadres to the
homes of the weavers as reported by
University of Washington a lecturer
Darren Beiler that they send hand-picked
Chinese cadres to the Weaver homes those
homes could be somebody who has been
taking in their wife and children left
behind or just normal wig or family so
they go in and live with them basically
they eat on their dining table and sleep
in their bedroom we have images we've
seen images and then the most jarring of
this family homestay programs is to
force the weaker kids to spy on their
parents
that's turn and the the kids honesty
based on disturbing reports that we have
seen resulted in some parents sending to
the camp the next day so it's been so
intrusive recently attended a panel
discussion the title of the the panel
was the other type of prison describing
the weakest
who are not in the camps an open-air
prison open-air prison so when you just
imagine that you try to have a normal
life you take your children to school
you stopped randomly by police subject
to biometric search data collection and
the iris scan in some instance you're
forced to give DNA sample if you if it
was not done previously and then when
you when you kids off to school the
teachers force them to you know answer
some private conversations like what
kind of conversation that your parents
have at home do they practice do they
teach you this and that and the
children's honest answer resulting in
their parents detention and also the
Weger kids have been forcibly taken into
a state-run orphanage the Chinese
government based on their own reporting
will fully institutionalize their
state-run orphanage by 100% next at the
end of next year which is about 22% now
so there is a rapid increase of the
construction of the orphanage which was
reported on BBC CNN and also the vice
news recently they look like a prison
you know barbed wires and tall gates and
cameras all around so I think the legal
scholars and policy experts are right
what they said that the Chinese
government is committing cultural
genocide
narrator kal thank you for joining us at
reason thank you very much for having me
for reason I'm Todd crane
[Music]